I'll keep this one simple.
There is a correct way to sign off an email.
It is "Best wishes."
"Best" and "All the best" are also acceptable.
Anything else?
Sorry, no.
"Yours sincerely"?
Too formal.
"Yours"?
Too intimate.
"Cheers"?
Okay for friends, but too casual for a professional context.
"BW"?
Tacky.
"Kind regards"?
Just a bit pompous.
Those are all terrible,...
...but my absolute least favorite email sign-off is "Thanks in advance."
What's wrong with "Thanks in advance"?
It's incredibly presumptive,...
...you can't thank someone for doing something before they've agreed to do it.
That's not how gratitude works.
When you say "Thanks in advance" in an email,...
...you're basically saying, "Hey, by the way, you have no choice whether to do this or not."
So, stick to "Best" or "Best wishes," and you can't go wrong.